on the mound for the san diego padres is
blake snell
well the left-hander making his 23rd
start and second against the phillies
this year
thrown 100 plus pitches four times this
year including the last three starts now
we got a door open in center field where
fernando is playing for the first time
and he's going to go close it looks like
fernando is ready for his first game in
center field now
swinging a foul tip into the catcher's
mid for strike three
first strikeout of the night for blake
snow
a one pitch
fastball runner goes pitches the strike
and the throw to second not in time
austin nola
has only thrown two guys out trying to
steal this year
aaron's brother and that was an
absolutely superb jump by segura first
move
pickup played second and he threw it
away
off the glove of chronoworth and
reaching at third as segura they had him
he was in no man's land
kind of twilight right now
elevates that harper strikes out
back-to-back case for blake snell
under the fastball to get it done in 96.
on the ground to short to the backhand
chronoworth long throw
it'll get there nice play
nice play on the other side too by eric
hosmer some fancy footwork
snell out of the jam gets some help from
his friends
check out this play and hosmer
with the fancy footwork to end the
inning matt moore making his 11th start
no doubt his last one was his best one
in fact it was probably his best one in
a long time
lines it and it's a diving grab by luke
williams for the second out of the
inning
really nice play by luke williams here's
a guy that doesn't play all that much
and he's really sharp i know he works
very hard
during pre-game and to prepare himself
in a variety of ways 2-2 to boom
that is strike three went to the
curveball to get it third k for snell
one down
that start was in right field first
because center field is better visually
if you're making that adjustment
swinging a miss that's four strikeouts
for snell that's a one two three second
inning for snell we're scoreless from
san diego
[Applause]
to left and that'll get in for a head
mccutcheon on the backhand quickly gets
to it the throw will go to third myers
is to second at second and third and a
double for will myers padres have
something going with two down here in
the second inning
facing his buddy matt moore in the hill
swinging abyss at a high fastball and
moore gets his first strikeout and it
couldn't have come at a better time
no runs one hit
three men left
[Applause]
to center field fernando making his way
back to make the catch
fernando tatis junior headed back
towards the warning track
and a fair distance to run but he reels
it in in his first try
in center field that went well
watch the flash look at the walls just
to see where he's at and also trying to
high five the bullpen secures the catch
and says hey guys
what do you think of my first catch
swing and a miss and he makes quick work
good morning five strikeouts now for
blake snell
[Applause]
there he goes the throw to second not in
time and segora has swiped two bags
tonight
he has nine stolen bases
and there was really no chance for noah
absolutely no chance again this is
another first move snell does not like
to pick over there and they obviously
know that about and then have scouted
them two out base hit and rbi would take
so much pressure off some of the guys
jt lines one to deep left field it's
going toward the corner and it's off the
top of the wall a runal score it's an
rvi for jt real muto a double and the
phillies jump on top one nothing
that one is golf deep to right field
forget about it it's gone down the
walkway
a two-run home run for harper and the
phillies
lead it three-nothing
wow tom this is about as good of a bat
i've seen this entire year from a
phillies ball player justin abs
tremendous at bat by bryce harper right
here
almost seemed like he knew what that
pitch was coming
kutchen strikes out but the damage has
been done in the inning
two-run blast for bryce harper a
three-nothing phillies lead strained my
left shoulder and when i was hitting
right-handed it was
it was scary to swing and especially the
swing and miss
check this swing did he go yes he did i
think he realized that he started
walking away gabe morales rings him up
that's a good pitch for matt moore
one out in the third for manny machado
and 102 machado
driven to left
it's back and it's gone line drive home
run
two run shot for manny machado his 22nd
of the year and the padres with one
swing of the bat right back into this
one it's 3-2 philly
serves it to left mccutchen diving play
another two outs
really nice play by mccutcheon right
there low line drive off the bat of
cronenworth he got a great jump
great read nice play
1-2 pitch
and both strikes out looking seventh
strikeout for blake snell is out number
one in the fourth inning
swinging a miss and striking out is
bonifacio that's three straight k's and
eight in all
for blake snell
[Applause]
and a strike three called on the inside
corner three strikeouts for moore and if
he starts getting that pitch
consistently then he's gonna be in good
shape
and a strike three called on the outside
corner yet again
four strikeouts
[Applause]
for matt ford
strike to recall
ninth strikeout for snell second time
matt morris down by way of the k
tommy pham is hitting 251 against
right-handers 200 against left-handers
this year he's got the righty naris
and he bounces it out towards shortstop
slowly hit the reyes has it throws on
the run and naris gets out of the jam
he is able to
hold on to this one run lead
no runs no hits three men left and now
mccutcheon
who is old for three
pulled into left field of base hits it's
going to the wall segora is on his way
to third rounding third heading for home
the throw to the plate by cronenworth is
cut off it's an rbi double for andrew
mccutchen it's career hit number 1800
and he gives the phils an insurance run
so here we go
base is filled with friars
and nando gets hit in the helmet
hosmer will score from third it's a one
run game but
all the concern right now is with
fernando tatis junior as he walks down
to first appears to be okay
that's strike two wow
it's a bad time to miss a call
out comes jace tangler
he's called a bundle of pitches off the
plate against the padres tonight that's
the night for jace swing and a miss and
machado strikes out padres will leave
him loaded for the third time in the
game and manny to say some more stuff to
doug eddings and now manny machado
ejected trying to stop the four-game
losing streak in the pitch
and a line drive caught at shortstop by
d.d gregorius and the phillies hang on
and win it by a final score of four to
three
you